[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département à ces
parties a pour le sommaire en ball-trap
s'est imposé ce week-end face aux
mureaux à domicile sur le score de 43 à
35 qui se rapproche du podium du
championnat prérégional nous étions sur
place reportage à suivre
apnée à xavier delpy 41 ans licencié à
versailles et anciens et dans courtois a
réussi à franchir la barre mythique des
100 mètres de profondeur sans respirer
en egypte nous aurons le plaisir de le
recevoir sur le plateau dans quelques
instants pour l'automobile le départ de
l'africa et corey sera donnée le trouble
décembre prochain depuis monaco a dit
vino attristant quid elle participera ce
rallye africain qui passera par le maroc
la mauritanie le sénégal il sera avec
nous enfin à des missions l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
je vous le disais dans les titres trap a
réalisé la belle opération du week-end
dans le championnat de pré régionale en
venant à bout à des mureaux le score à
43 à 35 pour les trappistes les images
du match sont signés à nicolas landry un
montage de sandrine fontaine
une victoire pleine de maîtrise pour
trappe ce samedi 24 novembre les blancs
et bleus n'ont pas tremblé face au mur
au dernier du classement de prérégionale
les trappistes l'emportent 43 35 dans
leur gymnase après un festival offensif
pense qu'elle est méritée on s'est tous
donné à 200 %
on a su jouer même physiquement jusqu'au
bout malgré des trous défensif qui nous
ont fait mal
certaines périodes mais sinon dans
l'ensemble ça a été de ces travaux
l'équipe en face était on va dire sur le
papier moins fort qui se sont renforcées
mais ça reste une équipe qui était
largement à notre portée normalement
mais une équipe que le leader a battu
que de six buts la semaine dernière donc
voilà on leur met sept buts
un résultat qui pourrait être un
tournant dans la saison des trappistes
cette deuxième victoire consécutive
permet aux joueurs de frédéric bélanger
de grimper à la 4e place du championnat
après huit matches disputés la montée
l'objectif du club semble accessible le
premier à deux points devant donc une
victoire étant à trois points tout et
tout est très serré et vu qu'il ya 2 2
places pour monter en région c'est
encore tout à fait faisable maintenant
faudra faire mieux mais voilà on est on
est on est on est dans l'est
on est dans les places on est encore en
vie trappes tentera de continuer ça
remonte à date dès le mois de janvier
prochain après la trêve hivernale les
trappistes se déplaceront sur le terrain
de ben on continue par du handball mais
cette fois-ci féminin
montigny-le-bretonneux me montigny
bretonne a lourdement chuté sur le
terrain de rouen lors de la 8e journée
du championnat de nationale 2 les
inhumant ten se sont inclinés à 29 à 20
à l'extérieur au classement les
yvelinoises reste à la 7e place avec un
bilan négatif de 3 victoires pour déjà
cinq défaites
place à la trêve maintenant pour l'euro
de handball féminin le prochain match
est programmé le 12 janvier contre
lisieux du basket à présent avec la 8e
journée du championnat de nationale 3
masculine trappe se déplacer sur le
terrain de vineuil les trappistes sont
repartis avec une victoire dans leur
valise ils se sont imposés sur le fil 72
à 67 dans un match très serré au
classement trappe reprend la deuxième
place à son adversaire du jour et
revient à un petit point de la première
place détenue à part poitiers en
football on joue et la 9e journée du
championnat de première division de
district toutes les équipes qui
recevaient se sont imposés ce week-end
plaisir remporte le derby contre
guyancourt 2 à 1 le fc mantois s'impose
largement 4 à 2 belle victoire également
de houille sur le terrain sur le score
de 3-0 contre gargenville marly-le-roi
domine le chine et 2,0 enfin à fribourg
s'impose 2 à 1 face à carrière crazy ion
et à sartrouville l'emportent 1-0 face à
montesson le championnat est toujours
dominé par marly le roi plaisir et
guyancourt complète le podium
on referme cette page rugby fait part de
résultats par deux résultats rugby
versailles n'en finit plus de gagner
dans le championnat honneur les versets
ils se sont imposés 20 à 15 sur le
terrain de clichy un résultat qui leur
permet de rester invaincus et surtout de
s'envoler au classement avec cinq points
d'avancé sur le 2e montesson et 10
points sur le troisième paris15 toujours
dans le championnat honneur mais cette
fois ci dans la poule 2 le sky rugby n'a
pu faire mieux que match nul 15 partout
à domicile face au red star lors de la
7e journée
au classement les saint quentinois reste
7e avec 2 victoires depuis le début de
la saison je vous propose maintenant de
prendre une grande bouffée d'oxygène et
de vous équiper de votre masque et de
votre tube à nous allons parler apnée
dans cette émission avec nous sur ce
plateau xavier à delpy licencié à
versailles ans un habitant d'elancourt
est médecin à l'hôpital de trappes
conçoit
bonsoir alors vous avez réalisé une
plongée en apnée à plus de 100 m nous y
reviendrons dans un instant mais avant
je vous propose de regarder le reportage
qui va suivre andy cabreira à vilains
franco-cubain de 46 ans maître nageur à
saint-cyr-l'ecole accumule les records
en apnée pour la bonne cause
une discipline qu'il pratique avec elle
qu'il pratique avec passion depuis son
enfance des images d'eux patrick jacques
de dixmude
[Musique]
gérer son souffle ses émotions pour
repousser toujours plus ses limites
le quotidien dandy cabreira avila le
franco cubain de 46 ans est considéré
comme l'un des meilleurs apnéistes de
france une discipline qu'il pratique à
la piscine de saint cyr l'école alors je
m'entraîne beaucoup à sec
ces dernières rumeurs soir sur la chaise
de sauveur sur la piscine et pendant
qu'il surveille les clients je fais ça
voilà lieu blog ma respiration ou
minutes au menu 30 demain traîne aussi
dans l'eau à la santé
une ou deux fois par semaine le sportif
réalise aujourd'hui des records à couper
le souffle
et à chaque fois pour la bonne cause en
2016 pendant six heures on dit réaliste
694 longueur en apnée pour récolter des
fonds pour une enfant malade en 2017 il
passe 24 heures dans l'eau pour le
téléthon les sports ça leur met des
départs ce no limit
mais si en même temps en parallèle les
dépassement de soi il ya aussi on cause
pour laquelle nos tient à coeur et on se
dépasse 50 plus émérites des records
toujours plus fou que ce maître nageur
et imagine chez lui aux essarts-le-roi
sur les murs de son appartement la mer
encore et toujours cuba et bien sûr les
tenait alors ici c'est mon petit paradis
je prends des souvenirs que je me suis
sûr à l'entraînement sont des choses qui
me tient très à coeur
ici c'est un mois à cuba
alain paul burel à mon stage ça fait il
y aurait 20 ans j'ai toujours amoureux
de la nature et le défend la médaille de
la déprime d'honneur la médaille
d'honneur de la ville d'essentiel écoles
c'est un espèce de reconnaissance pour
leur confort de tous que le faire à
bessines
c'est ici également que le sportif cache
son plus précieux trésor celui qui lui a
permis de baigner dans cette passion
c'est petit livre je tiens mon plus beau
coup à ces lieux voilà et de la colère
quand j'avais 4 ans 1974 à l'école à la
biotech et parlent et 20 contre histoire
d'embêter d'enfants il raconte tout ce
qui y voient à la mer donc depuis l'âge
de 4 ans j'ai découvert qu est ce que
vous voulez faire dammarie ces extraits
font doucement donc à 80 on va faire
découvrir la mer jusqu'aujourd'hui la
mer et la protection des animaux marins
des thèmes toujours plus chère à andy
pour défendre cette cause l'athlète
réalisera en février prochain défi passé
plus de deux heures 42 en apnée pendant
trois heures et tout cela avec un
déguisement de dauphin les parcs
aquatiques ont adressé les dauphins et
ses dauphins ont amené dernière des
clous ls esclaves pour servir les placer
à des landes des causes qui devrait
amener andy a replongé pour de nouveaux
records dans les prochaines années au
moins jusqu'à ses 90 ans
la remontée à la surface attendra
xavier delpy une réaction par rapport à
ce reportage vous connaissez bien andy
cabreira mendier vote un bon ami et puis
la planète un petit monde donc on se
connaît un quasiment tous est vraiment
très grand coeur et une ténacité
exceptionnelle pour tenir ses records ce
à l'extrémité l'apnée on a plutôt de
parler de trails ou d'extrême treille
pour andy dans l'année puisque ses
distances courtes mais qui répètent sur
des durées infinie ans les échelons avec
une récupération infiniment courte et il
faut vraiment avoir un courage
exceptionnel pour tenir son rythme sur
la durée qu'il fait mais suivait avec
attention c'est tous ses records j'ai pu
être avec lui dans l'eau à ses côtés
pour l'encourager sur des petites des
petits passages et dès que je peux me
libérer je savais de grand plaisir ce
que c'est toujours pour la même cause
alors nous allons maintenant revenir à
vous allez donc réalisé en egypte il ya
quelques semaines une plongée en apnée
en poids constant de 101 m et une autre
de 111 m en poids variable pour vous
présenter un petit peu ces disciplines
qui ne sont pas forcément très connus du
grand public
alors le poids constant et la discipline
pour nous un petit peu phare de l'apnée
la plus prestigieuse probablement ou
descend à la seule force de la palme du
guide et sur 1 sur un filin dont la
profondeur est déjà fixé avant la
descente puis on remonte avec le même
poids à la palme jusqu'à la surface donc
c'est un effort en autonomie complète le
poids variable est pas une discipline
pratique en compétition mais avec
quelques record homologué où on descend
à l'aide d'une gueule un petit peu comme
dans le grand bleu mais par contre on
remontre pareil à la palme en autonomie
totale
vous avez décidé de le faire en egypte
et pas en france ce record ce record
mais en tout cas cette affluence ce
record personnel parce qu'il commence à
faire un petit peu frais à cette saison
en france même si on s'entraîne souvent
tous du côté de villefranche à côté nice
qui est un très beau site d'entraînement
pour la profondeur ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'en egypte les conditions de mer sont
toujours à permettre de s'entraîner et
plonger tous les jours une grande
profondeur juste à côté de l'as côté
surtout un centre la bâche à un check je
suis andrea zuccari qui pour moi le
meilleur en termes de sécurité et
d'apprentissage sur les éléments qui me
manquait pour progresser en profondeur
justement je prépare combien de temps
pour une telle performance soit fait ça
fait plusieurs années un exercice
ordinaire qu'est ce que j'ai un petit
peu
exprimez c'est que ça fait cinq ans pour
moi que j'y pense que je m'entraîne pour
avec des éléments des clés à chaque fois
qu'ils peuvent manquer il ya énormément
de préparation physique dans l'année
c'est peut être deux entraînements de
crossfit par semaine en régime
d'entraînement régulier deux séances
d'entraînement en natation en nage avec
palme avec mon coach en iran au chai et
qui gère aussi ma préparation physique
c'est de l'hypnose avec mon
hypnothérapeute pascal jacquinot cosson
pour préparer le mental tout ce qui va
arriver et ce qu'on veut mettre en place
et puis des entraînements en apnée pure
qui le commet 10 messieurs variantes
différentes pour des apnées très longue
et très poussées et puis des stages
entre guillemets ou moi je pars pour
quinze jours trois semaines m'entraîne
exclusivement profondeur pour acclimater
l'organisme et les poumons grande
profondeur ce que ça se fait pas du jour
au lendemain il faut énormément de temps
pour que la physiologie on va beaucoup
plus loin que dans n'importe quel sport
sur le plan c'est l'hiver et des organes
pour qu'il puisse réveiller nos réflexes
de mammifères marins est allé en
profondeur le fait d'être médecin c'est
un avantage pour eux c'est probablement
quelque chose qui m'a un petit peu plus
de compréhension des mécanismes que je
veux mettre en place après ça peut avoir
le défaut éventuellement si je suis pas
ouvert à d'autres choses de m'enfermer
un petit peu disciplinés de ce qui est
connu souvent les api sont un petit peu
de manière empirique comme souvent
précurseur sur ce que les médecins
découvrent après donc c'est assez rigolo
de passer d'un monde à l'autre
est-ce que ça
ça se prépare aussi mentalement aussi un
record comme celui là est ce qu'on se
dit à un moment voilà il faut que je
passe les 100 mètres parce que vous avez
été plusieurs fois aux alentours des 100
m mais pas à 100 m est-ce qu'on se
prépare plus spécifiquement pour le pôle
sceaux m cette année pour la première
fois et je pense que j'étais prêt à la
fois physiquement mais ça allait
probablement depuis plusieurs années et
là il ya un travail mental qui est plus
spécifique qui a commencé cette année
donc en hypnothérapie qui a été je pense
très intéressant et qui a été une des
clés qui a permis de débloquer cette
nouvelle frontière
quels sont les futurs objectifs pour
vous alors les futurs objectifs
là j'avais fait un petit break de
compétition ce que c'est pas évident est
en équipe de france est en compétition
internationale pendant des années avec
le métier qui est le mien j'ai besoin
d'un petit peu de repos de ce côté mais
là le maintenant que les performances
sont là l'envi revient et donc ça va
être un des objectifs avec les
championnats du monde
haidar à nice l'été prochain donc ça
sera une très belle occasion qui s'y
remettre si toutes les étapes sont
validés merci à vous vous avez des
alpilles d'être passé sur ce plateau
encore un grand bravo pour votre
performance et on continuera à shinobu
suivre avec attention
et n'hésitez pas si vous faites d'autres
records n'hésitez pas à nous contacter
merci beaucoup
on reste en mer le versailles et éric
bellion est toujours engagé sur la route
du rhum le skipper est actuellement
large des canaries avec sa goélette
baptisé comme un seul homme ils pointent
toujours en dixième position il fait
face à des vents modérés
éric bellion fait également parler de
lui dans l'actualité cinéma etc son film
intitulé comme un seul homme qui sortira
dans les salles le 13 février prochain à
un long métrage qui proposera une
immersion avec le skipper sur son
dernier vendée globe
regardez un extrait
lannoy
mon bateau heureux
[Musique]
fervent donner des
il faut jouer
[Musique]
mais
c'est mon second élu dégâts
la du gros gros dégâts on prend
maintenant la direction du vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
rapport d'activité de vélo police
exploitants du vélodrome nationale sur
l'année 2017 a été dévoilé la structure
a accueilli seulement 35 mille personnes
sur des activités à titre commercial
comme des séminaires des baptêmes sur
piste ou encore des projets
événementiels les activités liées à la
présence des équipes de france de
cyclisme ont quant à elles généré à 6060
visiteurs pas suffisant pour être
bénéficiaire la structure affiche un
résultat d'exploitation en déficit de
650 3000 euros pour booster la
fréquentation du site l'ucp à l'union
nationale des centres sportifs de plein
air qui gère déjà à des piscines des
centres équestres et des patinoires va
remplacer à vélo police je vous propose
maintenant de découvrir la capoeira le
club belo horizonte d'elancourt installé
dans la commune depuis 11 ans organisé
des rencontres internationales au palais
des sports une trentaine de
professionnels sont venus de france et
d'europe pour participer à ce rendez
vous des images de nicolas landry
[Applaudissements]
enfin venue du brésil flotter ce samedi
à elancourt les rencontres
internationales de capoeira été
programmé au palais des sports
un rendez vous organisé par le club
local de belo horizonte pour moi c'est
très très important parce que 0
j'ai beaucoup des années que vient
d'être agréé pour participer avec moi et
partager cette romance énergie avec moi
que cette énergie là car parmi les
participants une trentaine de
professionnels de france et d'europe
leur objectif transmettre leurs savoirs
et les techniques de cet art martial
venu du brésil technique ça vient avec
le temps de façon c'est la pratique
phénomène comme on dit au brésil l'est
au niveau des techniques au niveau des
séquences qu'on apprend à chaque jour la
musique
la vente des fois aussi donc c'est ce
côté là contre mais le plus beau bien
que bien développer la grave les maistre
sont également venus pour faire passer
des grades aux adhérents du club
d'elancourt
et forcément la pression était au rendez
vous d'échangés avec les maistre les
moniteurs et les contremaîtres passé un
peu genre ya de l'adrénaline les mairies
qui joue très vite beaucoup de réflexes
on va se faire taper tout ça
d'ailleurs il faudra patienter pour
revoir à elancourt un événement de cette
envergure le club belo horizonte devrait
organiser les championnats intervilles
mais le rendez vous est fixé à 2020 au
palais des sports
on passe maintenant notre page agenda on
commence cette page agenda par de la
course automobile tristan couëdel
originaire de hub la russe va participer
du 30 décembre au 13 janvier à l'africa
eco race un rallye automobile qui
reliera monaco sénégal en passant par le
maroc et la mauritanie pour nous parler
de son aventure nous recevons très
stanco edel bonsoir tristesse
bonsoir pourquoi avez vous choisi de
participer à cette compétition alors
historiquement mon associé on a un rêve
fou que l'on poursuit depuis maintenant
quatre ans et de réussir être à
l'arrivée du dakar celui qui se déroule
en amérique du sud
on avait tout imaginé pour repartir de
cette aventure
et puis le fait que la course est un
contexte un peu particulier puisqu'elle
ne traversera qu'un seul pays cette
année ça restera au pérou du coup on
avait un rêve secret avec mon associé
c'est de toute façon un jour ou l'autre
de retourner en afrique est donc là on a
décidé d'anticiper ce retour est de
faire donc l'africa eco race et pourquoi
l'africa eco race du coup plutôt que le
dakar fait enfin moody's est c par
rapport au pays mais également peut-être
voilà la formule historique du dakar
également pas exactement ça rejoint un
petit peu ce que j'ai eu la chance de
vivre en 98 puisque j'avais la chance de
faire des jaloux vaquin en afrique et
puis après deux infidélité finalement
revient en afrique qui nous paraît assez
logique avec mon associé et co pilote
sont donc laissés du coup le désert
africain quels sont les pièges les
pièges c'est oui c'est l'éloignement
absolue c'est à dire que en mauritanie
on a vraiment l'impression que quand on
est soit de lomié du désert on est
vraiment seul et on sait que la
civilisation est ce qui nous rassure
tout au long de vie que l'on vit en
europe
typiquement tout ça est très loin et la
mauritanie assad un peu particulier
alors vous avez déjà participé du coup
dakar de deux éditions vous l'aviez dit
est ce que vous comptez vous appuyez sur
votre expérience pour démêler les pièges
oui en fait l'idée c'est que je sais que
la clé de la réussite dans ce type
d'épreuve c'est de l'ultra lucidité
c'est un petit peu ce qu'on évoquait
hors plateau avec votre précédent
invités c'est finalement dans la
réalisation de performances
l'hyper lucidité est absolument
nécessaire et j'ai vu pendant cinq ans
puisque j'accompagnais des équipes télé
sur le dakar en amérique du sud
énormément de concurrents perdent leur
lucidité je sais que moi même comme tout
humain je un risque de perdre la
lucidité donc je veux lutter contre ça
et c'est en se préparant qu'on arrive
peut-être admis résultat la tuerie à
quel moment peut être on perd cette
lucidité plus vers le milieu de la
course la fin de la course où ça peut
arriver très tôt finalement ça peut
arriver tout de suite en fait là l'idée
c'est que le cumul de
chaleur de l'excitation de la fatigue
parce que clairement c'est pas une
relierait tu sais un moment on dort
vraiment très très peu surtout dans le
contexte dans lequel nous faisons avec
mon copilote ont fait nous mêmes notre
mécanique le soir
donc nécessairement en fin d'étape on a
encore du boulot et selon comment ça se
passe on peut dormir que très peu de
coups à 3-4 heures et avec le cumul en
fait des jours plus la fatigue le temps
passé sur la piste les galères sur la
piste à creuser poussé sortir la voiture
au final ce cumul c'est que voilà on
perd sa lucidité c'est là qu'on fait des
erreurs et c'est là qu'on peut
potentiellement abandonné commente le
père est aussi son sang froid aussi
dans ces moments-là écran coéquipiers
oui c'est un espèce de huis clos
abominable et c'est pour ça que ça avec
mon associé dans la vie au niveau de
notre société est en fait c'est un
challenge aussi puisque finalement on
est en permanence confrontés à des
prises de décisions ensemble on fait ça
tout au long de l'année et là c'est une
manière de se retrouver et c'est un peu
particulier mais c'est un moment fort
quoi très intenses se répare combien de
temps la vence pour ce type de
compétition
disons qu'il sera parti physique ça nous
a nécessité de revenir à des activités
sportives plus régulière parce que
physiquement sinon la souffrance est
trop importante c'est à dire que l'on se
fait malmener dans la voiture en
permanence et les muscles sont
nécessaires pour maintenir le coffre le
corps et de la même manière quand on a
un souci qu'il faut creuser là le
physique va prendre le pas aussi donc il
faut de toute façon passé entraîné
physiquement
et puis ben là où l'on associé lui va
travailler plus sur la partie navigation
les instruments moi ça va être plutôt de
passer du temps derrière le volant pour
pour parfaire certains réglages dont on
peut le faire
oui je pense que oui enfin ça fait ça
demande énormément de choses dans les
différents domaines du jeu et c'est des
choses qui pour les obtenir pour avoir
cette maîtrise sa demande je pense de
l'expérience et c'est peut-être un
domaine où le l'ag - - un enjeu que dans
d'autres sports
ça demande aussi peut-être un budget
conséquent si pour partir oui ça fait
partie des nerfs de la guerre on le sait
les sports mécaniques sont son cher
c'est une pratique et qui demandent donc
en plus de passer en amont par une case
qui
et la recherche de partenaires être
capable effectivement de motiver des
gens d'avoir des gens qui vous aide et
d'aller au bout du projet voilà c'est ça
fait partie aussi c'est de l'épreuve
avant l'épreuve c'est être au départ
d'une épreuve comme celle-là c'est déjà
avoir parcouru un chemin parsemé
d'embûches du coup avec vos coéquipiers
comment comment vous appréhendez les
choses est-ce que vous est ce que vous
êtes stressé peut-être ou est-ce que ces
camions connaissez parfaitement
non on est on a finalement d'en découdre
après il ya toute cette phase
préparatoire qui est excessivement
longue faire que la voiture soit au
point que et puis c'est un calcul il
faut préparer des pièces d énormément
d'éléments en amont se projeter de que
va-t-il nous arriver on a nos angoisses
de nos deux précédents abandon qui vont
faire qu'on va orienter notre quête de
la panne dans une direction n'est
évidemment pas la bonne puisque
nécessairement les problèmes seront
différents puisque à chaque fois c'est
différent mais voilà c'est vrai que ça
participe à la chose c'est qu'on essaye
d'imaginer toutes les situations et on
n'arrive jamais ça empêche de dormir
bien évidemment aimé parfois ça peut
aider quoi votre véhicule est prêt pas
du tout pas du tout pas du tout on a été
de charybde en scylla imaginer
effectivement d'avoir une année de
préparation et finalement à force de
solutions techniques en voulant avoir
forcément la meilleure solution
on a changé deux fois d'orientation et à
force avec le cumul avec les ennuis
mécaniques qu'on peut avoir
effectivement se retrouve avec une
voiture qui a roulé assez sûre s'est
avérée elle a roulé il ya trois jours et
remonte en région parisienne pour
parfaire certains éléments pour les
tester aussi fenêtre avant et juste
après et il ya toujours cet enjeu se
tenir en la testant je risque de
l'abîmer
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui va générer
une panne quand je serai sur la piste en
mauritanie donc il ya tous est en jaune
et oui on va rouler on a prévu des
séances de roulage
de manière à être partir serein vous
avez testé ou alors on a déjà des pistes
autour de chez moi c'est l'intérêt
d'habiter uluru entrée fonds de la
région parisienne au fond du 78e encore
des pistes qu'on peut pratiquer et qui
permettent de reproduire pas exactement
la mauritanie mais des choses qui
ressemble un petit peu et votre objectif
ça sera quoi sur cette compétition alors
dans notre cas c'est réellement où les
terminer avant tout terminer avant tout
ses rails réaliser ce rêve
en 98 je n'avais pas non plus vu dakar
en tout cas pas avec la voiture de
course et pas dans les temps en donc là
moi je rêve depuis que je suis gamin
d'arriver puisque le l'arrivée se fait
au lac rose de la même manière comme à
la grande époque comme on a tous ces
images du des voitures qui arrivent
après ce périple incroyable d'arriver au
sénégal à dakar
donc voilà je jeu j'ose imaginer
l'émotion qu'on pourrait avoir d'arriver
au bout de cette belle aventure humaine
on vous souhaite en tout cas merci
beaucoup ce récent coup edel on espère
vous revoir à votre retour sur ce
plateau
ce sera avec plaisir en tout cas merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup en football le
tirage du 8e tour de la coupe de france
a eu lieu la semaine dernière les
derniers représentants évinois
versailles qui évolue en nationale iii
recevra le mythique rc lens dans son
stade mont boron une équipe où a évolué
pendant six saisons l'actuel gardien de
versailles charles itandje aujourd'hui
âgée de 36 ans
la rencontre est programmée le samedi 8
décembre à 13h30 au stade maubon donc et
on referme ce magazine par une dernière
information la vie chinoise caddie
baradji à 29 ans réussit à remporter de
nouveau le titre de miss fitness france
une nouvelle distinction après celle de
l'année dernière caddie baradji
notamment professeur de zumba et à la
pratique le sport au moins à 25 heures
par semaine
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine à 10
il a passé une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur atv soit
[Musique]